hey this is press tow
Walker you're working at an amusement
park and the food vendors tell you what
percentage of the visitors eat each of
their Foods 65% eat a dut 80% eat a
pretzel 80% eat a slice of pizza and 90%
have ice cream the Geniuses in marketing
want to sell a bundle of all of the
foods but they want to know how many
people people are actually interested in
it so they call upon you a mathematician
to tell them what's the minimum
percentage of visitors that must have
eaten all four
Foods I thank James for the
suggestion pause the video if you'd like
to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this
[Music]
problem
I'm going to present multiple ways to
solve this
problem it actually was very difficult
for me to understand it first but now
that I've seen the solution it seems so
easy so let's get started with one
method let's imagine there are 20 people
who are visitors to the amusement park
now 65% of 20 is equal to 13
people 80% of 20 people is equal to 16
people
that's true for pretzels and a pizza
slice then 90% of 20 is equal to 18
people so we know the number of people
that ate each of the foods and we know
the number of people that didn't eat a
particular food it is theoretically
possible that 65% of people ate all four
foods but we don't want the maximum
number we want the minimum
number so the way we can figure this out
is we can distribute the number of
people who didn't eat a particular food
so that they don't
overlap so here we have people who
didn't eat particular foods and we want
to spread these out as much as possible
so let's take a look at the people who
didn't eat a
pretzel we'll stack these right next to
the people who didn't eat a dut so we'll
shift these people
over now we'll do the same thing for the
pizza SL SCE we'll take these four
people and we'll shift it all the way to
the left of the people who didn't have a
pretzel finally we'll do the same thing
for the two people who did not eat ice
cream we'll shift it all the way over to
the left of the people who didn't have a
slice of
pizza so now we can see there are a
total of three people who did eat all
four foods and that's out of 20 so the
minimum number has to be 3 out of 20
which is 15% of all people and we can
visually see that in each of the other
rows there's at least one person who
didn't eat all four foods and that's the
answer now here's another way you could
solve it using vend
diagrams so let's start out with just
two foods of donuts and
pretzels so here are the total visitors
and here we know that 65% ate a doughnut
that means 35% did
not now let's say of the 35% who did not
eat a doughnut these are people who had
a pretzel but did not have a
dut so how many people must have had a
pretzel and a donut we need to get up to
80% so 80 minus 35 will be 45% that had
a dut and a pretzel
so we'll move this to the side and now
we'll do the same sort of calculation
for pizza and ice cream there are 80% of
people who had a slice of pizza that
means 20% didn't we'll take all those
people and say that these people had ice
cream but not pizza so that would mean
we need 90 minus 20 which is 70% who had
both a slice of pizza and ice cream so
that'll be the number of people who had
both of these
Foods now we can imagine dut pretzel as
a food and we can imagine Pizza sliced
ice cream as a food so 45% of people ate
the first food item and 70% of people
ate the second food item so how many
people ate both we'll do the same
calculation again so 45% ate the first
item that means 55% did not eat it now
we put that into the second Circle so we
need need to have 70 minus 55 so that
will be 15% of
people so once again we figured out at
least 15% ate all four
Foods now here's a possible trick which
will make the calculation very simple
imagine there are 100 people so these
percentages just become whole
numbers now let's add up all of these
numbers 65 + 80 + 80 + 90 which equal
315 so
315 food items were eaten now let's
suppose each of the 100 people ate three
of these items so 3 * 100 is equal to
300 so we're still 15 food items
short now for each of these food items
each person could only have at most four
of the foods so each extra item has to
be an extra extra person so this will be
15 people who ate all four Foods then 15
out of 100 is equal to
15% and once again we get to the
answer now we just want to show that
this is minimal so let's do it in a
little bit of a formal way let's denote
these sets as WX Y and
Z for any sets A and B the size of a and
the intersection with B will be equal to
100 minus the size of the complement of
a union the complement of B these are
for A and B being sets of
100 similarly the size of a union B will
be less than or equal to the size of a
plus the size of B so let's apply this
to the sets WX Y and Z the size of the
intersection of all of these that's what
we want to figure out this will be 100
minus the size of the Union of their
complement
but then we use the inequality so we
have 100 minus the size of each of these
complements so that'll be less than or
equal to the size of the intersection of
all these
sets we know the size of each of these
complements it'll be 100 minus the size
of each set so we have 100 - 35 - 20 -
20 - 10 and this is equal to
15 so we know that the people who wa all
four Foods has to at least be 15 and we
have actually shown that we can
construct this so that is the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time